bueno bienvenido pablo gracias
generalmente los creativos se los asocia
mucho en el ámbito de el guión la
dirección los actores y un sos productor
y la mano derecha y el socio de
sebastián ortega no en muchas de las
series que nombraron películas también
algunas no se nombraron todas las de
pablo porque daría para mucho pero
historia del clan graduados tuberos el
rol del productor el rol creativo cuál
sería
el rol creativo del productor está ante
todo en encontrar los talentos en cada
una de las áreas y encaminarlos sin
causar los hace un objetivo común que
tiene que ver tal vez con un en este
caso no hablando la industria
audiovisual con la realización de una
serie una película o con cualquier
contenido de ficción de todos modos el
más allá de encontrar esos talentos
existen el productor artístico porque
así somos también más allá de ocuparnos
de presupuestos armados programas
marketing comercialización generamos
nuestros propios contenidos por lo tanto
la idea madre surge de la productora y a
partir de ahí vemos quiénes son las
personas ideales para acompañarnos en
ese camino en ese proceso creativo
y la verdad que en ese punto la
creatividad es igual que en todas las
personas
decíamos que del mismo modo que el
cuerpo físico genera sangre el cuerpo
espiritual genera creatividad por lo
tanto todos lo somos es encontrar
aquello que nos representa qué es lo que
cuál es la historia que todos tenemos
siempre hay una historia que todos
tenemos y que tenemos ganas de contar de
expresar que nos identifica que nos
perturba que nos provoca a partir de ahí
es encausar la no encausar y encontrar
los elementos que necesitamos para que
eso se transforme en este caso en una
historia que le interesa al resto del
público porque no quiere decir que todas
las historias que nosotros nos suceden
van a ser interesantes para todos es
encontrar lo que nosotros llamamos el
sentido del espectáculo y aquello que va
más allá de mi bebé mi vivencia personal
y ahí es donde los productores podemos
hacer que un artista que tal vez es
genial y maravilloso pero que le cuesta
trascender al gran público puede
encontrar su lugar y sacarlo de ese caos
creativo que tiene que existir porque la
creatividad técnica mercado
anarquía pero de algún modo encontrar la
manera de que esa persona tenga más
firme sus fortalezas y atenuar sus
debilidades para que eso llegue a buen
puerto y sea más masivo en el marginal
bueno mucha gente la está viendo en
buenos aires en argentina ni te hablaron
a dos lados obvio
mucha gente está esperando en el freezer
helados y 100 días para enamorarse la
están viendo en un canal de aire acá ya
desde hace un tiempo poniendo un ejemplo
de esos dos procesos creativos de cómo
se fueron dando como es el hecho
creativo en todos los días en la
realización de esas dos series por
ejemplo son muy diferentes por supuesto
que nosotros cuando somos una empresa
digamos que tiene un fin comercial
industrial por lo tanto tenemos que
pensar no solamente en que queremos
contar sino cuál es el objetivo
comercial el que perseguimos por ejemplo
que se vea más allá de las fronteras
argentinas y cuáles son cuál es el
público que podría llegar a ver lo que
se está necesitando en el mercado en
este momento entonces el caso del
marginal tuvo que ver con un momento
especial en donde la televisión pública
nos pide una ficción en un canal en
donde hay muy poca
en cuanto a la audiencia masiva por lo
tanto lo que dijimos es tenemos que ir
con un contenido potente y que nosotros
tengamos ganas de poner digamos frente
al espectador y ahí surge un poco lo
mismo que nos había pasado hace muchos
años con tumberos que nos tocó una
emisora de muy baja audiencia y fuimos
una historia potente y fuerte como es el
género carcelario que de por sí es un
género exitoso en todas partes del mundo
pero bueno hay que encontrar este
justamente que es lo que a nosotros nos
hace genuinos con respecto a esa manera
de contar y lo que nos sucedió
a medida que empezamos a entrar en ese
mundo y dices un mundo que es muy
importante cuando otra es la historia o
tienes el género decir bueno me voy a
meter en el mundo de la cárcel más allá
de todo lo que se me puede ocurrir tengo
que cumplir con patrones básicos de
relato
el famoso camino del rv digamos cuáles
son los arquetipos los protagonistas los
antagonistas más allá del contexto en
particular y de la potencia que tiene
que tener la ley de una estructura que
funciona debería debería tener una
estructura para que esta estructura azul
para que el programa funcione les llega
el gran público más
o sea del cuento y más allá del relato
más allá de la historia que quiero
contar y después bueno investigar ese
contexto porque bueno puedes tocar de
oído digamos que es que que se va a
hablar de la cárcel tenés que conocer
cuál es la realidad de la cárcel que vas
a retratar una vez que conoces de su
universo vos lo rompes a tu antojo ahí
está la parte en donde la creatividad
vuelve a ser rupturista y digo bueno yo
con esto que hago y hago un mix de
testimonial por llamarlo de algún modo
de lo que puede ser una cárcel
latinoamericana con el humor negro más
mordaz que le da un tamiz a la historia
que la hace más soportable si no sería
muy fuerte ver todo el tiempo las
vejaciones que ser una cárcel entonces
entre el humor negro más la crueldad más
despiadada sólo encontrar el tono y eso
también forma parte de la creatividad un
programa es el armado es la forma que le
das una idea primigenia ese fue un poco
el caso del marginal en el caso de señas
para enamorarse que va a otro tipo de
público en un canal el líder como telefé
y en el horario en nuestra la familia
reunida dijimos bueno vamos a contar una
historia que nosotros nos interpela que
hablamos de cosas que tenemos ganas de
hablar nosotros
gente de 40 y pico de años muy mayores
salvo todo lo que tenga contar la
historia de parejas modernas de gran
pareja que que hoy en este momento
sienten que no todo está perdido y
quieren salir del hastío del matrimonio
después de muchos años y teniendo en
cuenta la mujer y el emponderamiento
femenino como debe ser
son ellas las que toman la decisión putt
en el tablero y quieren vivir una nueva
revancha en la vida que vienen llevando
ese fue el plan iniciales en vidas para
enamorarse como tópico a partir de ahí
las historias que salen o se manifiestan
como ramas de un árbol de cada grupo
familiar o de cada grupo de trama y ahí
surge la historia de la chiquita
transgénero donde nosotros teníamos
ganas de contar esa historia pero
también teníamos la necesidad de ver qué
le pasaba al público poniendo sobre la
mesa un tema de reflexión y de debate
esos para el debate social el que tiene
que ver con la inclusión con la
diversidad que son temas que nos gusta
a nosotros transitar y en ese punto es
justamente donde acompañamos el proceso
del personaje junto a lo que el público
le viene pasando y en lo que el público
va sintiendo y a partir de ahí logramos
lo que lo que nosotros llamamos un
entretenimiento que tiene el mismo
tiempo un contenido social que aporta al
menos el debate y que genera también
discusión reflexión pues no ha perdido
ni muerto pero theo el debate en la mesa
en la familia en la sociedad de algo que
estaba tapado y que se hace visible
bienvenido sea
fue más notorio ahora cuando estuvieron
en el parlamento de ustedes votando la
ley de del aborto
bueno por ejemplo otra excluyeron ese
tema a partir de que empieza a suceder
con el entretenimiento familiar o de
parejas
que tenía estas comedias románticas y
poder introducir estos temas y generar
de algún modo un mensaje positivo en la
sociedad y también digo de algún modo
hacer docencia con algunos temas
sentimos que la actualidad
estaba necesitando el programa estaba
necesitando de esa actualidad que el
público nos pedía hablar de cosas de
todos los días donde donde se sentían
representados identificados en ese
contexto cuando viene el tema de la ley
del aborto el día el día que el senado
tenía que dar su veredicto que fue
negativo que imaginábamos que así iba a
ser el programa de algún modo tocó el
tema de manera abierta en la clase donde
van los adolescentes y el profesor
plantea lo que va a suceder en la noche
en un par de horas diciendo que se va a
tratar este tema quiero explicar qué es
lo que se está tratando y quiero
escucharlos a ustedes opinar obviamente
estaban las dos campanas y a partir de
ahí hubo una bajada de la parte
ideológica que tiene la gran parte de la
producción cuando lo que producimos
respira todos los que lo hacemos que fue
que que sea lea y no se cerró un poco la
escena y ahí quedó plantada cuál era
nuestra
nuestro mensaje con respecto a la
situación sin dejar de que se escuchen
las dos campanas creo que eso es muy
importante y eso le empezó a aportar al
programa una identidad y una
personalidad propia que es fundamental
para que lo trasciende
con todo el proceso creativo se va
formando durante el transcurso de la
tira mucho mucho porque somos muchos los
actores digamos desde el punto de vista
de los que participamos de todo el
proceso obviamente los productores
artísticos en los directores los autores
ni te hablar de ella y él y los actores
los actores los que interpretan las
escenas en la televisión es un trabajo
en equipo en donde más allá de que tiene
que haber una línea que termina siendo
verticales eso bueno hasta acá vamos o
vamos por acá también está el canal que
opina desde ya el canal que lo emite
porque tiene la responsabilidad
justamente de emitir en ese punto todos
opinamos y participamos siempre teniendo
en cuenta la historia principal el
camino o el arco dramático que se generó
en el primer capítulo hasta el último lo
que vas haciendo es justamente viendo
cuál es el termómetro social con
respecto a lo que vos estás comunicando
para ver por dónde llevar la cosa para
que sea más efectivo
público eso pasa más que todo en la
serie diaria que se hace prácticamente
el momento que se emite no tanto en las
series que uno ve terminada que después
suenan las plataformas como puede ser el
caso del marginal en donde tal vez sean
haces un análisis de la temporada
posterior a decir bueno en la temporada
en la primera temporada la rompe el
personaje de diosito por decir algo
bueno la segunda temporada la
protagonista ese personaje
qué bueno justo de los uruguayos uruguay
y también hizo algo creativo a la hora
de ser seleccionado para el marginal
bueno por eso digo que todos somos
creativos y en la en la limitación es
donde más surge ese talento que todos
tenemos en el caso de nicolás hurtado
que era un típico actor pero con por
favor por su aspecto físico más cercano
le galán por formado algún modo y el
prejuicio que puedes crear en este caso
que le jugaba en contra cuando siempre
éstos jugaría a favor en una serie que
se buscaba gente de un aspecto físico
diferente lógicamente desde el arquetipo
que uno tiene de la gente que está presa
entonces qué es lo que él hace él
al casting sin decir que era el más allá
no era una figura tan conocida pero un
actor que tenía cierta trayectoria un
casting de más de 1000 personas y se
pone una prótesis en la boca esos
dientes que ustedes después vieron los
que vieron el marginal que utilizó
supuestamente según nos cuenta dormir la
villa una noche bueno hizo un montón de
cosas que tenía el pelo ya herido tenía
el pelo teñido el pelo fue esto eso fue
un agregado de ver después estética
claro pero obviamente que todas estas
cosas no nos enteramos otro el momento
de la selección el viene compone el
papel interpreta como él se le ocurre
ese personaje y así va pasando la
distintas instancias pero si él hubiese
venido como era tal cual interpretaba
seguramente desde la producción
hubiésemos tenido cierto prejuicio con
su aspecto físico porque no era
directamente proporcional a lo que
imaginábamos él se ganó el personaje con
esa idea que nos trajo y no solamente
sucede eso sino que incorpora hasta esa
prótesis en la boca a partir de ahí
bueno sucedió lo que sucedió con él y
con su frase con con su gran presente
como actor
vamos a hablar un poquito del ser
creativo decís que todos somos creativos
y acs
buenos aires- un taller de escritura y
de producción y de creatividad
con jorge maestro que sobre los
guionistas de hace años de la televisión
y el teatro argentino no consideras
realmente que todos somos creativos que
todos podemos crear que
en todos los aspectos de la vida hasta
para subsistir a que se busque es muy
creativo más en estas épocas pero
digamos si vamos a lo que tiene que ver
con el mundo del espectáculo del arte de
la cultura audiovisual
lo notamos continuamente con gente que
con la que interactuamos y que como
decía al principio más allá de cuál
termine siendo su camino en esta
profesión en esa búsqueda siempre
tenemos algunos campos digamos algunas
herramientas como para poder dejar en
claro cuáles son nuestras posibilidades
del punto de este creativo y más allá
del talento que tengamos por supuesto
que siempre existe el genio siempre
existen las personas extraordinarias que
no necesitan ningún tipo de herramienta
de nada porque por si solas
éste demuestra el talento que tienen la
creatividad que tienen pero como decía
antes que sería de muchos artistas si
hubiesen encontrado quien los encauce
quien los lleve por el camino justo
nosotros alguno de los ejercicios que
hacemos siempre y que están basados un
poco en algo que escribió julia cameron
el autor americana que escribió el
camino de la artista y aquí sí que es
muy interesante poder hacer es esto de
dejar drenar las
ideas que surgen cada mañana cuando nos
despertamos escribir en un libro en
libros en un cuaderno o en el ipad o en
el celular requieran las primeras
sensaciones imágenes sentimientos que
tenemos lo que soñamos a la mañana
dejarlo escrito y dejar que se seque
vivir sin parar esté bien sin parar sin
ningún tipo de juicio sin ningún tipo de
pensamiento crítico ni siquiera de
primero de producción
de escribir desde el corazón desde el
corazón surgen cosas maravillosas y con
el tiempo y cuando eso se tiene que
transformar en algo más profesional hay
que rever los y reescribir lo desde la
cabeza y ahí es donde aparece tal vez la
parte más de producción en donde tenemos
que encauzar un poco ese material que no
tiene que ser juzgado como les dije que
no es que no nos tiene que provocar
enojo sino absoluto placer y que se
revisa y se reencontrará revisa y nos
empezamos a dar cuenta de que todos
tenemos algo para decir que todo tenemos
una historia para contar que todos
tenemos una imagen que nos emociona que
nos cautiva que nos provoca
y que nos trae algún recuerdo ingenuo y
seguramente si eso es genuino y es
realmente no algo elaborado sino que
sale de las tripas digamos va a tener
una relación con el material posterior
ese que sí va a tener que ser repensado
en funciones de producción en funciones
de contar una historia que les llega al
gran público tenga una estructura mucho
más efectivo que si hubiésemos puesto ya
desde el vamos un montón de
condicionamientos en cuanto en ese
proceso creativo te alimenta lo que
ocurre vamos a llamarle la afuera pero
el afuera es lo que puede pasar con tus
amigos lo que ocurre en la sociedad lo
que lee lo que dice bueno desde ya que
más allá de ese ejercicio que tiene que
ver con lo digamos con la cuestión más
interna de nosotros y con nuestros
sentimientos más profundos el contexto
en el que estamos viviendo nos determina
de que ya y esto tal vez es lo que hace
que después esa misma historia tenga
otros condicionamientos y quería bueno
este es el aquí ahora esta historia de
la cuenta
y quiero decir esto porque es oportuna
porque puede ser efectiva porque puede
provocar algo en el otro entonces más
allá de y muchas veces todo esto que
estamos sintiendo no es que lo tenemos
que transmitir de manera directa al
amparar la transmisión directa se hace
en ese momento después obviamente que
hay algo que es más metafórico que es
más conceptual que lo proyectamos en
otro personaje en otra historia que otra
vez nosotros no somos ni siquiera
nosotros mismos y por supuesto que tiene
que ver con como decía antes según el el
público al que nos dirigimos según él el
programa que estamos haciendo es qué
tipo de cosas podemos manejar no es lo
mismo hacer cien días para enamorarse
con esto que le estaba diciendo en donde
se cuentan historias de carne y hueso de
que ahora es una historia como el
marginal en donde los personajes
conviven en una acción es en una
situación extrema de violencia y tal vez
el humor es lo único que libera
aquí ya te diste cuenta que podías vivir
de un trabajo creativo
y la verdad me di cuenta mucho después
que lo empecé a hacer o sea nunca fui
demasiado consciente porque a mí lo que
me movió siempre fue la pasión por los
relatos me movió siempre la pasión por
contar historias por por actuar por
recrear otras vidas eso ya lo tengo
desde chico
lo que me empezó a pasar porque fue más
fuerte que yo porque digamos estudié
periodismo entré en la televisión y
estaba estudiando estudia comunicación
social y en la misma televisión se fue
dando la posibilidad de entrar en el
mundo de la ficción que me apasionaba
por el cine y por el teatro y cuando
llegó el momento de digamos cuando ya
estaba trabajando en eso un día dije
están pagando por esto
lo que me pasó a mí fue que tuve la
bendición de poder trabajar en lo que me
gusta hace más de 25 años que lo hago y
que me que siento que el motor más
grande que tengo con respecto a esto es
la pasión por lo que hago que va muy de
la mano de la creatividad o sea yo
siempre digo que ninguna persona vaga
puede ser muy creativa porque la
creatividad exige también un trabajo la
creativa no la puedes dejar sola y de
vez en cuando la osea todo elemento que
sentimos que nos hace volar que nos
provoca que nos emociona hay que
trabajar sobre eso hay que darle una
fuerza impresionante a eso para que eso
se transforme en algo concreto tangible
sino de qué sirve algo que es creativo
pero que no se manifiesta nada y creo
que por eso es muy importante sentir
mucha pasión por lo que no hace porque
pero el germen parte seguramente de algo
que nos motiva y que tenemos ganas de
expresar y de contar y sentir que nos
representa y puede conmover al otro y
cuánta gente aproximadamente trabajan
alrededor de una serie depende los casos
en el marginal trabajaron más de 500
personas más allá del grupo técnico y de
actores y de producción y dirección
voten encontrar los extras bueno a toda
la gente que hace la realización de una
serie en 100 días debe haber alrededor
de 200 personas son grupos muy grandes
más allá que hay un grupo más chico que
es el que lleva adelante un programa que
parte obviamente de los autores en la
cabeza creativa en la producción general
de los directores y el elenco principal
a partir de ahí son las ramificaciones
pero muchísimas la gente de trabajo
tiene mucho que ver con tu vida en las
historias los relatos no desde niños muy
chicos si desde muy chico creo que la
primera vez que me emocioné con una
ficción y que creo que algo que 2000
germen
y fue cuando vi este extraterrestre
steven spielberg la habrán visto que el
culo es un clásico del cine
y recuerdo que sea de chiquito jugaba
que quería hacer
con un perro que yo tenía un perro
pequinés lo ponía una bicicleta
el perro me levante el dedo por éxito
como éste
y bueno encontraba la manera buscaba la
forma de que ese dedo pobre lo de haber
quebrado como estoy yo ahora al perrito
y a partir de ahí tengo es la sensación
de la emoción que a mí me provocó eso la
magia que me hizo pensar y soñar y soñar
y como yo quise recrear eso y dije con
el tiempo me di cuenta que esa emoción
cambio provocó spielberg con el amor al
diferente porque de eso hablé te hoy lo
podemos hacer es real en cien días para
enamorarse con mensajes que hablan del
amor aquel que sueña siente y ama de
manera diferente o sea que hay un arco
dramático en mi vida que se cierran se
vea para enamorarse del humor pablo y
cuanto limita la creatividad entre
supuesto que es el tema que siempre
puede estar rondando cualquier
producción mira podría tomarlo al revés
decirte que en las limitaciones cuanto
más creativo no tiene que ser lo que no
te tiene que pasar es que nada te
congelé que nada te frene no tengo para
esta idea la quiero hacer es este
programa lo quiero hacer esta canción la
quiero cantar este cuadro lo quiero
pintar pero no tengo los elementos no
tengo la plata bueno lo hago diferente
le encuentro la manera la gente no mira
las excusas
y yo me siento y digo miren el marginal
en realidad
tenía que salir 2 millones de dólares
pero tenemos 100 mil entonces desde una
cárcel enorme a una cárcel chica por la
general y por la gente ve lo que ve
entonces yo le estoy presentando eso por
lo tanto todas todas las excusas y todo
lo previo todos los problemas que
tuvimos para hacer no se van a terminar
de ver se va a ver lo que se ve entonces
nosotros le tenemos que dar el mayor
amor a eso porque todo lo demás lo
olvidamos ese termina siendo el producto
y entonces creo que en la limitación
esto que decía todos tenemos fortalezas
y debilidades y en un programa de
televisión podemos tener una gran
creación un elenco maravilloso una
historia buenísima y tenemos no tenemos
plata como pasa en casi todos los países
de latinoamérica para producir bueno
esto lo atamos con alambre pero que no
se note
y en ese y en ese potencial miento de
esos actores maravillosos que tenemos de
esos autores increíbles esos técnicos
increíbles de algún modo vamos a
soslayar las debilidades presupuestarias
entonces es adaptarnos todo el tiempo
los productores somos solucionadores de
problemas yo soy que hoy a la mañana
empieza a agravarse pero voy a tener 70
cosas que resolver
yo estoy así de tranquilo a ver cuál es
el primer problema muy bien como siempre
le digo a mis productores chicos un
problema tres soluciones a ver a veces
con cuál nos quedamos siempre se puede
resolver aparte en el mundo de la
creación en el mundo de la comunicación
y digamos y de la industria audiovisual
tenemos la maravillosa el maravilloso
beneficio que lo que hacemos es
entretener a la gente y en una de esas
la posibilidad de generar docencia y de
abrir cabezas pero no somos gente que
tenemos que salvar vidas que eso sí
sería mucho más preocupante entonces
relajemos no no se nos va a morir nadie
como muchos abrir alguna cabeza vamos a
hacer reír a alguien vamos a emocional y
vamos a hacer que un chico el día de
mañana recuerde esa película como yo un
día récord spielberg y hoy entre un
grupo grande de gente podemos realizar
una ficción que a mucha gente la puedo
mover bueno bienvenido a que de
montevideo de este año gracias por tu
tiempo muchísimas
[Música]